BEHIND.
THE BLUES HAVE ALLOWED THE FIRST
GOAL AGAINST OR NINE OF THE LAN,
DEFEND THE MIDDLE CONOR GARLANDS
DOWN THE RIGHT SIDE, HE'S WITH E
WITH McKENZIE McEACHRON
COMING SIDE
>> John: THE BLUES AND
BUCHNEVICH.
ON FOR TARASENKO, WAITING,
FIND SCANDELLA.
NOW THOMAS LEAVES IT, DOORSTEP.
HE SEEMS TO HAVE KNOCKED THIS
IN.
HE WAS FIRST IN LINE
NOT AND FO,
OUT WEEK TO WEEK.
BODY.
GREAT PASSING HERE.
THOMAS AGAIN PUT IT UP HIGH OFF
THE BARBASHEV AND A
2-ON-1 WITH SAAD,FORWARD WITH GT
THERE IT'S POKED AWAY BY
BARBASHEV WITH ONE HAN FIRST TWO
PEPERIODS FOR CAROLINA.
>> John: A A
BARBASHEV, TOTHE LINESMAN, SO LO
PUT ON THE MIKKOLA. AGAIN. STICS
IT OUT. PASS BOESER'S PASS BLOCD
BY PERRON, THE BLUES TO CENTER
WITH NUMBERS, NOW WITH S S
>> John: MacEACHCHT WAS WALKER I
BELIEVE YOU'RE TEMPTED.
ON THE CYCLE.
THOMAS LOWE, WORKING AGAINST
A PIVOT.
THE CENTER ICE MENFINALLY TIPPE1
NOT THE BIGGEST PLAYER IN THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE, BUT HE'S
GOT A GREAT
>> Darren: IT WASN'T ON THE
HANDS.
IT IS K
AND GET YOUR MONEY'S WORTH FOR
WORTH.
>> John: EXACTLY.
BOESER IN N NOW BACK TO HUGHES,
J.T. MILLER WITH IT.
HE FLIPS ITCK TO HORVAT FOR
PETTERSSON, ROLLED ON HIM,
PICKED UP NOW
FRONT.ULL A GOALIE
THAT WAS BLOCKED BY SCHENN,PRAYE
TOP